wildlife biologists have designed a
drone that can hover within swarms of
bats as a zip across the nighttime sky
the drone is equipped with a microphone
to record echolocation chirps and a
thermal camera that can see bats body
heat the microphone is insulated and
that allows it to pick up high-pitched
bathrooms over the noise of the drone
itself and the phone prevents it
reflecting those chirps back to backs
similar technology has been used to
record bats from the ground and from
towers but the Cairo copter has the
advantage that it can be placed anywhere
in 3d space in testing the team
maneuvered the drone to hover in the
middle of a bat swarm in 184 minute
recording they recorded at Heights
ranging from 5 to 50 meters and there
were so many bats that they recorded 46
echolocation chirps per minute by
monitoring the swarms from the air the
researchers hope that they'll be able to
figure out how the fast flying mammals
avoid colliding with one another no bats
collided with a drone during the testing
you